Wow it was exactly what I imagined  heaven looks like right down to the  unisex linen tunics Annabelle ma cherie  hi I'm sorry I'm late for our coven I  was polishing my oyster Forks with a  cage for olive oil apology accepted and  then I have no reaction to anything else  you said I can't help but ask what's in  right now well this season I'm intrigued  by a symmetrical overalls and gora  toothbrushes and locally sourced Italian  flip-flops also there's a flirty trend  in beverages so you've had soy milk and  almond milk now try the hottest new  craze beef milk  it's like almond milk that's been  squeezed through tiny holes in living  cow's milk no no milk cost $3 a gallon  Annabelle's authentic hand strain teeth  the table beef milk that costs $60 a  gallon yeah and there's a waitlist this  woman knows business and it'd be  extremely jobs to be part of the grizzle  bit shall we discuss it in my yard  you